people can you please not bring your guy
and the integer poll a
that's what they're requesting after a
buncha guys carried military-style
assault rifle
into which a poll a franchise in Dallas
Texas
they were promoting their open carry
laws because you're allowed to if you
have a gun
you're allowed to openly exhibited and
bring it around into public spaces
but you prolly would just prefer you not
do that they've been
issued a statement display a firearms in
a restaurant is now create an
environment that is potentially
incriminating
on comfortable for many of our customers
a question when I and
to go on and say nope so please don't
bring guns into trouble they will give
you that
guacamole but we're gonna are you extra
a with a big big point that
yeah illegal or extra yeah I'm like yeah
I know it but i'm only got caught early
it's not break the American actor i've
the gods I have and it's going to be at
a premium
so these people they're bringing the
guns they're these are so right for
these are not just them
not just a handgun at a fast food joint
is urs or Apple but they have a right to
do it
so before we get jokingly be about them
should we defend their right
to bring their weapons tubal I mean
you now I'm slightly intimidated by
saying you know I don't know
summit gonna come out like me now pull
their weapons makers good lord reading
all the comments underneath his article
there is a IR demand people really want
that
second-amendment amendment upheld do you
the
I'm you know I think that there needs to
be some paper parameters that
though you know it's not like they can I
just pushed like my Canon
in through the door and the like just
say and then that me
you know I'm here dick openly Carey I'd
like a burrito or yeah
one for me and one for Mike and yeah and
i got really bad
for the you know burrito rappers that
need to come out
and you calmly asked Billy Bob to like
put their assault weapon back in the
track like it just doesn't seem like a
fair
pairing but yes so if you an integer
Poli and there was two guys sitting
there with assault rifles
on the table what would you do or I went
to Costa Rica to a pizza hut near the
guy outside with an assault rifle
and it freaked me the hell out but he
was just that Garrard
yeah he has a garden he had a sorrowful
I get it I mean
yes neither me it's tough when
it's like a the way in which you display
your right
is really scary yes you know that's what
everyone's afraid I have
and I think nations psalm this all by
having different kinds of chipotle ace
there's a Chipotle a hot where you can
have guns
and then there's Chipotle is where you
can only have guns
and there's like a algun Chipotle a like
a battle royale Chipotle
button well I like the normal chipper
like they have to have these ones that
have
only everyone has a gun and then the
normal Chipotle ace where they have that
trademark Chipotle a knife fight every
so often right so basically in the south
that's where the gun ones are the night
fights where compared to others liked
the guns in all kinds the city that be
like people
you know I just I just want I you know
it that I i want them to be able to have
their right on display but
I mean its weird way where you can put
your assault rifle in the car outside I
mean he won it with you want someone
steal a nap
Yahoo part or chrome though that when we
have these two
talks about guns that the comment
section always everyone demanding their
right that they immediately
you can even talk about it and say that
maybe you shouldn't be allowed to bring
its alright paul
into Tripoli be immediately take that as
they're coming for I can quickly
they can review your service if you have
no shirt no got back Glee but
if you're carrying your thought were
able with no shirt no shoes maybe
they'll have to allow UN now I don't
know
yeah I mean I think that there needs to
be a balanced
has it which is you can can it carry a
concealed weapon which would make sense
you know you have it on you still why do
you need to light the lamp around I just
don't understand
yeah hoping thing right at the end of
the day as well Yahoo Joe cause it's
moving yeah
that issue for me at least yeah doesn't
know you
I would the US will be there for you
this is really a change I i mean and how
do you know that my penis is mighty
yeah I think we've been for taking
temporary bring a helmet
i DIII as long as I can still get
diarrhea chip berlet
which it happens all the time really I
love Chipotle yeah hi I have to prove
anything I just swallowed like that
happen you write it I
support live like the Four Seasons yeah
I think they'll
I don't know it's just like those spices
and I seventy so spicy
try the mild sockets and now the always
get like a little tiny thing how a pain
you in there any later based on by eyder
whatever Tripoli days will help with
your order okay we'll go from there
we're not gonna besmirch to Paul II
Michelle
up